can we really call Black Adam a bomb it
certainly wasn't a hit Studio execs were
expecting not even pulling in 400
million on a reported 200 million dollar
budget black panther wakanda forever
amassed more domestically in just three
days than Black Adam did in its entire
run and the DC film fell to fourth place
in less than 30 days but Dwayne The Rock
Johnson got defensive at the mere
suggestion that his movie compared
unfavorably to wakanda Forever its major
rival at the box office he tweeted
there's no competition with the
established Global brand of black
panther compared to Black Adam and JSA
who a year ago no one even heard of
where new babies and have to grow
meanwhile when variety outright called
the film a bust Johnson pushed back on
Twitter saying our film will profit we
are building our new franchise step by
step not long after Johnson reportedly
leaked a misleading financial statement
to refute claims of the film losing
money an unusual tactic for a major star
to say the least